vamos a hacer un par de problemas más
acerca de gráficas de líneas rectas y
aquí tengo un problema que dice un
gimnasio está ofreciendo un trato a sus
nuevos clientes sus clientes pueden
ingresar al gimnasio pagando una cuota
de inscripción anual de 200 pesos y una
cuota mensual de 39 pesos aquí tenemos
39 pesos por cada mes y este de aquí
estos 200 pesos son de inscripción ahora
bien la pregunta me dice lo siguiente
cuánto costará esta membresía para el
cliente al final de un año y bueno lo
primero que quiero que te des cuenta lo
primero que sería muy bueno sacar es la
relación precio con la cantidad de meses
que nos quedamos y quiero que te des
cuenta que si nosotros nos quedamos un
mes dos meses cinco meses la cantidad de
meses que sean lo que tenemos que pagar
en un inicio son estos doscientos pesos
y déjame mejor ponerlo todo en pesos
todo está en pesos y entonces son 200
pesos de inscripción que forzosamente
tenemos que pagar a este gimnasio sea la
cantidad de meses que nos quedemos ahora
bien a esto hay que agregarle 30
nueve pesos por cada mes es decir si
nosotros nos quedamos un mes vamos a
pagar forzosamente estos doscientos
pesos de inscripción y además vamos a
pagar 39 por 1 es decir 239 pesos vamos
a pagar en total y si nosotros nos
quedamos por ejemplo dos meses pues
tenemos que pagar forzosamente también
estos doscientos pesos de inscripción
más 39 por 239 de un mes y 39 del otro
es decir 39 39 78 278 pesos por lo tanto
de aquí tengo mi relación del precio con
la cantidad de meses que me voy a quedar
ahora esta es la ecuación de una línea
recta y es igual a mx más ven cómo puedo
escribir esto de la misma manera que
está escrita esta línea recta pues bueno
esto es lo mismo que escribir 39 m más
200 y es que date cuenta de lo siguiente
en esta ecuación y es igual a m x + b x
es la variable independiente mientras
que iu es la variable dependiente déjame
escribirlo esta es la variable
independiente mientras que ya representa
la variable dependiente mientras que
ahora en esta ecuación que yo tengo aquí
abajo
es muy variable independiente representa
lo que representa la equis aquí arriba
mientras que p es muy variable
dependiente es decir que pueda jugar el
mismo papel que juega la yema en la
función de aquí arriba y es de 200 este
200 es me ordenada al origen es decir en
qué punto interceptamos al eje de las 10
bueno no es al eje de las 10 en este
caso sería el eje de las pez recuerda
que en esta ocasión no se representa lo
que representa que el 39 es muy
pendiente y una vez que ya tenemos esta
función de la forma mx más bien entonces
pues vamos a poder graficar lo que
tenemos aquí voy a dibujar estos dos
ejes a mano y espero que no me queden
tan mal lo primero que sé es que
nosotros tenemos que pagar 200 pesos sea
la cantidad de tiempo que nos quedemos
es decir en un principio tenemos que
pagar 200 pesos de inscripción entonces
estamos situados en este punto es decir
que en el mes cero estamos pagando 200
pesos que son los 200 pesos de
inscripción y después por cada mes que
pase es decir si pasa un mes aquí y
bueno déjeme escribir que este es el eje
de los meses
y por aquí tenemos el eje del precio de
lo que vamos a pagar dp entonces si pasa
un mes
nosotros vamos a pagar 39 pesos más
porque el mes vale 39 pesos es decir 200
pesos más otros 39 pesos por este mes
que nos vamos a quedar y nos situamos
aquí aquí va a ser el valor de 239 pesos
y si pasa otro mes pues entonces tenemos
que pagar 39 pesos más es decir 278
pesos y bueno yo sé que la escala tal
vez no sea la mejor o la más indicada
pero ya nos da la idea de nuestra línea
recta que tengo aquí y ahora vamos a
responder esta pregunta lo que nos
preguntan es cuánto vamos a pagar al
finalizar del año es decir 123 hasta el
doceavo mes es decir estaremos todos más
o menos por acá y como se ve que la
gráfica sería muy grande y se nos
amontonar y a todo entonces vamos a
sustituir a m por 12 de manera
algebraica y que me va a quedar que p es
igual a 200 más 39 por m pero m vale 12
entonces más 39 por 12 estamos viendo
que es lo que va a pasar en el mes
y cuántos 39 por 12 2 por 9 18 llevamos
1 2 por 3 son 6 más unas son 7 y después
ponemos un 0 aquí y es 1 por 99 1 por 3
son 3 y quitamos este de aquí 3 y me
quedan 8 9 y 7 son 6 16 llevamos una
traición a 4 468 entonces 200 mas 468
las 468 lo que me sale de 39 por 12 y la
suma de esto es 668 pesos que vamos a
pagar al finalizar el año es decir la
respuesta de este problema si nosotros
siguiéramos la línea recta con 668 pesos
pero bueno vamos a hacer otro problema
bobby y petra tienen un puesto de
limonada
ellos cobran 45 centavos por cada vaso
de limonada
así que 45 centavos por cada vaso de
limonada para cubrir sus gastos de
producción ellos tienen que conseguir 25
pesos así que 25 pesos cuantos vasos de
limonada tienen que vender para
conseguir sus gastos de producción así
que vamos a bautizar a nuestras
variables x 7 para que podamos graficar
esta función voy a decir que lleva a ser
la cantidad de dinero que ellos están
obteniendo que ellos están haciendo
están haciendo mientras que xv hoy a
decir que es la cantidad de vasos que
ellos están vendiendo la cantidad de
vasos que están vendiendo y bueno ya que
tengo quién es xy quién ejem como puedo
ver alguien como una función de x pues
voy a decir que james es igual a quién
bueno pues cada vaso vale 45 centavos es
decir 0.45 pesos por equis porque si
nosotros vendemos un vaso pues recibimos
45 centavos si vendemos 2 pues 90
centavos y así sucesivamente y date
cuenta que en este caso no estamos
recibiendo dinero por ninguna otra parte
solamente estamos recibiendo dinero de
vender los vasos de limonada por lo
tanto nuestra función solamente queda
así y es igual a 0.45 equis y ahora lo
que quiero ver y lo que me dicen es que
ellos tienen unos gastos de producción
de 25
y entonces lo que ellos se preguntan es
cuántos vasos tienen que vender para
conseguir mínimo estos 25 pesos es decir
si lleva el de 25 cuánto tiene que valer
x para conseguir que llevara 25 y no va
a quedar esta ecuación a 0.45 x es igual
a 25 estos 25 pesos que esto conseguir y
si de aquí despejamos x me va a quedar
que voy a dividir ambos lados de la
ecuación entre 0.45 esto se va y me
queda que x es igual a 25 entre 0.45 que
cuánto es eso a ver 25 en 3.45 y me da
55 puntos 55 55 55 y esto lo podemos
redondear a 55.6 pero bueno x vale 55.5
periódico ahora lo que quiero que veas
es que no podemos vender y bueno
asumiendo que no podemos vender medio
vaso tres cuartos de vaso lo que sea
entonces lo que necesitábamos conseguir
son cincuenta y seis vasos de limonada
mínimos para cubrir los gastos de
producción
estoy redondeando esta cantidad a 56
vasos
y esa es la respuesta pero cómo se va a
ver gráficamente este mismo problema voy
a dibujar aquí a mis dos ejes este va a
ser mi hijo de las equis este va a ser
mi que de leyes y si te das cuenta en
esta ocasión no tenemos la ordenada al
origen solamente tenemos una pendiente
de 0.45 que suena muy lógico si no
vendemos ningún vaso pues entonces no
ganamos nada así que voy a poner 5 10 15
20 25 aquí no me cabe así que volvamos a
empezar te voy a hacer un poco más
grande la escala va a ser mejor 10 20 30
40 50 y hasta acá 60 y entonces si yo no
vendo nada no consigo nada de dinero
después siguió habiendo diez vasos
entonces ganó 4.5 pesos y entonces bueno
voy a decir que aquí son 4.5 pesos aquí
son 9 pesos así etcétera entonces si
bobby y petra venden 10 vasos ellos
consiguen 4.5 pesos déjame ponerlo mejor
así vamos a borrar todo y empezar de
nuevo
así que borrón y cuenta nueva
acá voy a suponer que son 9 aquí son 18
acá son 27 un poco más arriba son 35 y
bueno en 10 vasos voy a vender 4.5 pesos
o sea que estoy justo aquí en 20 vasos
pues 9 pesos en 40 vasos voy a vender 18
pesos y bueno ya tienes la idea de que
la pendiente es como 4.5 y entonces si
yo juntos los puntos
tengo una extraña línea recta vamos a
suponer que esta es una línea recta y
ahora sí si pensamos en el costo de
producción en estos 25 pesos cuando yo
tengo 25 pesos entonces voy a vender y
déjame mejor hacer un poco más adecuada
esta línea recta porque esta línea recta
no aparece nada recta así que vamos a
dibujar una línea recta que tampoco me
quedó muy recta pero bueno ya lo estoy
intentando un poco mejor y este que es
mi costo de producción me dice que
cuando nosotros tenemos que conseguir 25
pesos entonces necesitamos vender en 3
de 5 y 56 vasos de limonada y yo sé que
tal vez no sea la mejor gráfica que has
visto pero espero que te dé una idea